jacques et paloma s'envole vers le sud
pour une semaine dans un gros complexe
hôtelier tout inclus une belle surprise
les attend à la porte de leur chambre
une invitation conférence où ils
recevront en cadeau un séjour gratuit
dans la même chaîne hôtelière attiré par
le cadeau ils se rendent à la conférence
et claque le piège se referme
jacques et paloma vont passer un
après-midi complet à subir les pressions
de vendeurs de vacances à temps partagé
l'étourdie épuisé il se laisse
convaincre et signe un contrat de dix
mille dollars qui les engage pour 30 ans
sitôt sortie il regrette cette dépenses
astronomiques mais impossible d'annuler
ce contrat car les règles ne sont pas
les mêmes qu'au canada
de quoi gâcher le reste de leurs
vacances
le fin mot de l'histoire ne cédez pas
aux chants des sirènes dans le sud
si vous acceptez un cadeau vous risquez
gros